5 15 on your friday morning what's cool
at school how about a career day
on wheels
while all elementary school career days
include great conversations about what
grownups do
along with tap dancing around questions
about how much you get paid what kind of
car you drive but not many career days
include mobile news bands or police
officers with their motorcycles
ron futrell and i talked to hundreds of
students at john hummel the other day
not only explaining how the eight news
now van gets the news to you from just
about anywhere but also showing the
students the computer video screens and
all the buttons knobs and dials that
make it happen we even did a decent job
of making some of them feel like part of
the eight news now team
las vegas
also at that the career day there are
firefighters in full gear attacking a
wrecked car to show the life rescue
process there's a fedex truck and a
driver a construction crane an operator
thanks to hummel for having us if you
know something that's cool at school let
us know cool at school under the
community tab at 8newsnow.com or just
email us coolantschool at school
eightnewsnow.com so it's so cool they
had the kids in groups cycling from one
visiting career day to the other so we
were after the firefighters in the
wrecked car and the kids came over go
what do you got yeah what did you do you
got
when the firefighters get sent to the
scene that's when the news crew shows up
right that's what we talked about right
it's sort of a cycle of life and same
with the police officers on the
motorcycles fedex truck was a different
story the crane operator a different
story but there was a connection between
the firefighters the police and the
eight news now well they probably
recognize the fedex truck they're like
oh those come to our house yeah they
bring presents